there are few studios that I feel
encapsulate that pure passion for an art
form one where no matter what project
they take on you know it will be given
the same care and attention as when they
first started where every frame exudes
that same joyous energy that reminds you
why you fell in love with this art form
in the first place and in anime for me
one of those studios was Kyoto Animation
I remember first hearing about KyoAni
when I watched Full Metal Panic form
ofyou and the second-rate and this was
before my young brain really
comprehended that different shows were
made by different studios but I noticed
that these two seasons just looked
vastly better than the first and I
wanted to know what the reason for that
was and it turned out that it was
because a new studio was in charge of
these new seasons Kyoto Animation their
mark of quality was what made me strive
to find them out they were the first
studio I knew by name because of this
and even though this is vastly different
from the types of shows they're known
for now one thing that has stayed
consistent in all these years is that
same drive for quality I'm not going to
pretend that I've seen all lights
everything they've made but it's
impossible to deny that their work is
imbued with a certain magic and I think
that's why they're so loved and
respected by many of us in this
community I can't count the number of
conversations I've had with people who
couldn't stop crying during Clannad who
had nichijou to thank for gut-busting
laughter after gut-busting laughter who
were taught the value of family with
dragon maid got inspired by Kumiko's
journey in sound euphonium and yes were
deeply moved by some cute girls and
their [ __ ] tea
violet ever garden last year which I
initially thought I didn't like ended up
raising their inconceivably high bar of
quality even higher having moments that
took my breath away
and of course not forgetting a silent
voice which was such a raw delicate
depict
of the smallest tragedies you find in
life even disregarding the countless
tears I shed during this movie it blows
my mind that out of all the epic
monologues witty exchanges and outspoken
characters on display elsewhere in anime
the one character who could communicate
more succinctly than any of that was an
anime girl who had trouble vocalizing
gasps single word that is the magic of
Kyoto Animation while writing this I
tried to think of what word encapsulates
everything this studio is about and the
best I could come up with was touching
the studio has this mystic ability to be
able to craft these beautiful stories
that connect with an audience in a way
not many others can sometimes they're
cute
sometimes they're funny sometimes they
can flex amazing action sequences just
for the hell of it but peeling back all
those layers these are stories that have
touched and moved a whole generation of
anime fans that couldn't be more
thankful to have discovered their work a
few months ago I took to re-watching the
entire hierarchy series for absolutely
no reason no plan to mention it in the
video no tweet about it I just wanted to
re-experience it for myself
and I hope you understand that for
someone in my position this is extremely
rare Hera he changed me as an anime fan
as a teenager who was only interested in
flashy shown in action or cool mecha
battles this show was so out of left
field from anything I thought I'd enjoy
so I watched it with the pretense that I
was probably gonna [ __ ] on it as another
dumb overhyped high school anime and
Here I am over 10 years later with a
massive grin on my face that not a
single person could wipe off just
because I got to hear this track again
I can still hear Kieran's monologue
everytime this comes on even back then I
could tell how much passion went into it
I never knew some high school anime
could look so vibrant and alive
I slowly started to fall in love with
this group of misfits the school
festival episode floored me sending me
down a spiral trying to find every music
anime I could and then there was Keown
whose snarky wit and sarcastic comments
when you know it resonated with a
certain other snarky sarcastic British
get watching it but the real turning
points was the disappearance of Haruhi
Suzumiya which now after having recently
re-watched it I can firmly say is still
one of my favorite anime films of all
time it showed me that behind Keown
snark and sarcasm there was just a kid
who truly cared who was scared to lose
everything that he took for granted his
choice is a scene that will forever be
ingrained in my memory because no matter
how many wars of cynicism I erect as I
grow older there will always be a part
of me that still yearns for that same
childish joy you could feel when you
were a kid this is just one of the
stories they've made
that has touched me and I'm sure many of
you watching will have your own stories
and memories of how some of their works
have affected you in some way people
finds different ways to express their
passion for something they love and this
was mine I don't play piano I've never
had lessons I've never owned one I can't
read music sheets and yet one day on my
roommates keyboard I decided I wanted to
learn this song that was used and
disappearance by essentially just
watching covers on YouTube and trying
the best I could to fumble my virgin
piano hands into copying what I was
seeing on screen and apparently I beat
it into myself so deeply that I can
still play it today there wasn't any big
reason why I decided to dedicate several
of my evenings doing this to this day
this is the only song I'm able to play
on piano but for me this is a mark I'll
always have because those evenings I
took to learn a song when an instrument
I never played was my own way of
expressing how much I loved this movie
and how deeply it affected me
[Music]
I don't even know if the people who made
this are alive anymore nothing can
prepare you for the complete shock to
your system when you're given the type
of horrible news that leaves you stunned
and speechless and last week that's what
happened
34 deaths 35 injured the worst mass
murder to happen in Japan since world
war 2 for a studio that only has around
160 employees there aren't any words
that exist that can encapsulate a
tragedy such as this you see the
headlines and try to form the right
words to say but nothing that comes up
even seems remotely adequate enough when
you hear of a tragedy you instinctively
search for information and details that
can help you comprehend it why did this
happen what was the motive what was the
events leading up to this that would
cause such a horrific act to happen but
it's in that fruitless pursuit you'll
come to the same sickening realization
that no matter what information you
learn about it there is no way you can
fathom it there is no silver lining no
way to make it better no closure to be
had it just hurts it really hurts I wish
there was something we could grasp onto
something that didn't make us feel so
helpless in the face of what's been
taken away and can never be replaced I
can't even begin to comprehend the
twisted fate that would allow such a
tragic event to happen to a place that
brought so many smiles for our anime
community this is by far the worst thing
that's ever happened and it's put into
perspective how small and connected our
community might still be when mainstream
media outlets are reporting on this pray
for KyoAni is trending worldwide and yet
this feels so oddly personal if you like
to help out there is a GoFundMe by
Sentai Filmworks or if you want to
support your Annie directly you can do
so by purchasing some of their digital
prints on their website links in the
description for all the information you
need I will be donating
a hundred percent of the first two weeks
adsense of this video before turning the
ads off along with a thousand dollars of
my own money if I was ever thankful I
have any kind of reach it's so I can
help spread this word and even if I've
just convinced the fear of you to help
out too
it'll all have been completely worth it
normally I try to end these kinds of
videos on a hopeful heartwarming notes
and though I'm proud of this response
the community has given there is nothing
that could make up for the devastation
that's happened so I'll end this the
only way I know I can - everyone at
Kyoto Animation to everyone who has
managed to put a smile on my face
touched me moved me in some way and even
though hurts to say to everyone who I'll
now never be able to express what their
work meant to me from the bottom of my
heart thank you